everything
all right we're live
and assalamualaikum
welcome back to the realest podcast
and for those of you that don't know and
are new to our channel smash that like
button let's get this at 10k likes and
this is not homswortz's first rodeo with
the three muslims is it you've been here
before
yes i have i think i've done it
once or twice before yeah yeah we got
two episodes from like a year ago guys
links are going to be in the description
if you want to catch those gems we got
unhealed 2 a lot of new folks here that
are like who's the third muslim brother
the third muslim is different every
stream
it's on her bro how are you doing
the love bro just grateful to be here
all right allow this to be a beneficial
stream we will be back and by the way
guys this is live now pre-recorded we
see your comments right now we will be
back in five minutes
yes
can you guys hear us everyone talk say
something
hello
all right
i think all
is
good only thing is
i don't think they can hear you guys
right now don't know why
say something else please
okay now something else something else
you guys hear me
i think uh nah nah i can't hear you bro
come on bro okay audio's fine all right
welcome everybody today actually first
before i even start i want to say
that uh this stream is going to be
completely just intellectual strictly
intellectual academic um we're going to
talk about science the philosophy of
science
some of the things that don has
mentioned we're not going to sit here
and insult don
right like like he does to some other
people and like other people do to him
we don't want to see anything in the
comments that's insulting towards him we
don't want anyone going to his stream
and insulting him i don't know if he's
live or not but his videos not stuff
just call us it is what it is we don't
like the things that he says but we deal
with them in a proper manner insha'allah
as we will see with uh
hamza sources today and without further
ado let's get into it you guys want to
just uh play the first clip here you're
cool with that yeah let's do that all
right
all right so i don't think you guys can
be able to hear it but i'll play it for
the the viewers and then okay we'll just
go from there
scientific error number one
surah 86 versus or is 5-7 let the people
consider that they were what they were
created from they were created from a
spurred in fluid stemming from between
the backbone and the ribcage now i there
are dozens of scientific errors in the
quran i just picked four of what i found
to be the funniest ones
um
this one is hilarious so the quran is
saying that sperm
is cut originates from between the
backbone
and
the ribs the rib cage this is that area
right there for those of you who can't
see that's a smaller image right there
this is where it supposes that sperm
originates
now we know biology says that your sperm
comes from where your testicles
if you were to remove your testicles you
will no longer be able to produce sperm
it ain't got nothing to do with what's
going on up here
can we all agree that this is the rib
cage and this long thing coming from the
neck all the way down to the top of the
um pelvis is the backbone
and so what is in between these two
things if you were to draw a cross
section y'all remember doing venn
diagrams in math class it would be
somewhere around this area somewhere
around the lungs heart
air
all right
so
initially and i hope everyone can still
hear us i think there's a little bit of
lag but hopefully it's good um
regardless inshallah after the stream
will get it dealt with so he uses the
argument that allah he this is what don
claims allah says in the quran that
basically sperm is created from between
the backbones and the ribs
so
is that what allah says in the quran and
what is the muslim response to this okay
good so i've i've done a full formal
presentation but i'd have to skip
all of these slides just to go to the
responses because in the beginning i
talk about
the quran the philosophy of science and
you think that's better if we we covered
that first
well we can but since he's raised this
let me just address this and then we
could go from the beginning maybe yeah
and we'll come back to the point one by
one too yeah absolutely so
where are we
okay all right while you're finding it
everyone in the comments is saying freed
responds
sent to us
so shout out to freed responds may allah
bless you
thank you for sending viewers here
parade is is
he is the don
that's all i have to say also
donated 125 dollars thumbs up guys let's
enjoy
uh what our friends have to say
i mean
good so by the way we have a thing with
the three muslims i told them
which is obviously true but they say
it's it's a way of uh it's it's uh
an expression of endearment yeah yeah so
i so now henceforth i'm going to be
called the protein chef
and chef not actually i had my protein
ice cream just a few minutes ago about
half an hour
so
chapter 86 verses five to seven and this
is about the error of where sperm comes
from
now so
allah says in the quran in chapter 86
verses five to seven
man should reflect on what he was
created from
he is created from a spurting fluid then
he emerges from between the backbone and
the breastbone
and the this is this is the summary of
the contention the quran says that the
sperm comes from between the backbone
and the ribs this is unscientific the
sperm comes from the testes or the
testicles which is not between the
backbone and the ribs okay now before i
get into them just fix my light to
apologize
need to lift this thing there you go
okay so
that's the contention now there are
various ways of answering this
contention but before i get into the
answers
the scientific errors narrative so
people who say that there are errors in
the quran scientific errors in the quran
for them to show that the quran is wrong
they would have to show either
the opinion that they think or the view
that they think the quran is talking
about
is the only interpretation and that
interpretation goes against established
science
or
what they should do is that all the
valid different interpretations
all of them go against established
science
in order for the scientific errors
narrative to actually have any strength
they have to do that
and it's impossible
because
they would have to assume there's only
one view and that view is the view that
they think the quran is talking about
and they think that view is actually
going against the step of science and
that is never the case with these
accusations
or what they could try and do that they
may agree and say fine there are many
interpretations many views of what these
words can mean
and each interpretation of the words all
the verses or the verse
the different interpretations
they they are all unscientific and they
all go against
established science and again that's
even
that's highly unlikely more unlikely
than the first option because you have
more views now right more different
interpretations and many of them are
most likely to be accurate at least in
line with a naked eye understanding of
reality
so they can't it's very very difficult
for the scientific errors in the quran
narrative
to actually
hold any weight
um
because of what i've just said so it's
very important to mention this and and
the reason i'm mentioning this because
it's very important that they may find
scholars of the past or even maybe of
the present
they may have interpretations that go
against established fact or established
empirical reality or established science
that's not a problem
we're not denying the fact that we have
a rich tradition over a thousand years
and
thousands of scholars had different
views based within a valid
hermeneutical framework a valid
executive framework right
so
um
we accept that there could be views from
certain scholars that
thought that a verse meant something and
what they
thought it meant goes against
established science today that's not a
problem it would only be a problem for
us if that scholar's view was the only
view and the only valid view and that
view actually goes against established
science but that's not the case and
that's why it's very important for us to
um
to to mention this from the beginning so
regards there's various answers to
answer to to do with this contention
answer number one
first and foremost we have to understand
the quran does not mention the word for
sperm or any word that can connote sperm
that can mean sperm for example allah
uses the word
fat or
in the quran which refers to a my new
drop of fluid so if you go to the
dictionaries like
arab and many other classical
dictionaries and not far is
a
really small my new drop of fluid okay
and that is more in line with if anyone
were to you know
refer to the term sperm in the quran
that this word would be more in line
with that but the quran doesn't use that
at all
allah subhanahu wa tala uses in the in
this verse in these verses verses 86 to
uh five to seven
allah uses the word for water or fluid
all right so allah used the word ma for
example
which means fluid or water so
the conclusion we can make here is that
the quran does not use the word sperm in
in these verses
and therefore the first part of the
contention is totally misplaced however
and i should have mentioned this in the
preliminary video that even if it did
refer to sperm it would still not be
inaccurate
because as you would see and we're going
to discuss this in a few moments
the term
can also mean loins not just backbone
backbone and the testes are actually
between the loins and the ribs
right it's so if you if you view
to mean the loins
the testicles are between the definition
of the lines is like you know whatever
is just
from the pelvic arch i think and above
or the area where you you know you know
your underpants you put underpants on
right um
or i don't know what you call it in
north america
i don't know you call it something else
but you know because you pants for you
guys trousers so what's underpants
what like underwear
yeah there you go
underwear so your underwear or the
traditional
was it briefs whatever you call it um
that is your loin area right so if you
take the valid classical meaning for the
term
not to solve not only to mean backbone
but to mean loins then the testicles are
between the loins and the ribs
simple as that so even if
his false understanding of this verse
were true
in this case that the quran is talking
about sperm here
it would still be true
it wouldn't be a s it wouldn't go
against a step of science because the
testes are in the loin area when you put
your briefs on or your underwear on
you're covering the loin area in that
area
if you imagine that area and above it is
obviously the rib cage
so between that
is lo and behold the place where sperm
is produced which are the testes so i
wanted to put that in there
just to show that even if his false
understanding of the meaning of the word
was true his contention is still false
okay
so the second answer is
well before we get to the second answer
let's unpack some of the key key words
that the quran uses that are relevant to
our discussion today
so allah mentions
which the root for that is
so you have so the meaning the classical
meaning for this word is to exit
to issue to emerge to come out and to
leave yeah and this is used in various
places in the quran in chapter 3 verse
25 chapter 23 verse 20 chapter 5 22 and
this is very important to know this is
what the word means okay
now
the rule is saad
and the classical meaning is loins or
backbone now what's very interesting the
root can also mean to become hard or
rigid that's the root but the word
itself means loins or backbone
and you and it means collarbone upper
chest or ribs and so this is very
interesting for us to know the many
layers of valid meaning in the classical
dictionaries okay
now
there are many views of the quranic
exegetes
scholars
and three of them include the following
number one it refers to gushing fluid
exiting from between the backbone
backbone or loins and the rib for
example this is a view of ibn kether and
many others in actual fact one would
argue most of the scholars had this view
the other view is that it refers to the
baby coming out of the womb okay
and this is a view that al could be the
classical scholar
who predates this kind of scientific
understanding if you like
and even even
he had very similar views they his their
views specifically were that there is
within the rules of quranic exegesis and
us
the principle of quranic exegesis using
the language and so on and so forth
that the verse allows the meaning that
this refers to the baby coming out of
the womb and we know the womb is between
the ribs and the backbone and by the way
the backbone in the arabic
language
includes the tailbone and obviously the
word itself
um
uh
also means not just the backbone but the
loins could be the loins and the ribs
and we know the womb is in between that
yeah
and obviously this is the the the
understanding of the modern
scholar professor abdul haleem from soas
university university of london
the third view is
that
well
these two words
and these
are
kenai as if you like it's a kenaia it's
a linguistic indicator for something
so and this is not the view of
which i mentioned in the in the previous
preliminary video although it's
mentioned in his tafsir he cites someone
he cites an authority so just to be a
bit nuanced yeah
and so
he cites a
an authority and he says
a solabi is a linguistic indicator for
the male 1 and
is a linguistic indicator for the female
all right so what is
the loins or the backbone right the
backbone and remember the linguistic
indicator or the root for the word
also means to become hard or rigid yeah
which is an interesting
inference that you may want to make
um so sub is the linguistic indicator
for male 1 and
is the linguistic indicator for the
female so the backbone and the ribs
right
the backbone and the ribs so therefore
it could refer to sexual intercourse and
when the male ejaculates is between the
male backbone and the female the ribs
because ribs is is an indicator a kenya
for female and backbone in this case
is a linguistic indicator for the male
so
and it's between those two
entities if you like that the gushing
fluid uh you know
happens right because of
the sexual union between the the male
and the female so this is like a
if you like a
what word can we it's like a rhetorical
way
of
indicating the sexual union and what
happens right so that's another another
view in our classical tradition i'm not
saying you have to accept that view but
it is a view
and
it's actually allowed within the
language itself because
he he when he cites his authority
they
it also cites another verse that
actually um contributes to this
understanding so the point here is
there's three main views it is the fluid
and it comes from the backbone or loins
and the rib between those two things
number two is the baby that comes out of
the womb
and uh it's oh finally number three
it is that uh
is a kenaia is an indicator for male and
a torah ib is a linguistic indicator of
a female so this could indicate the
sexual union between the two and the
obviously the ejaculatory fluid happens
as a result and it's between those two
entities yeah
so that's the summary of those three
views so since those three views exist
well let's discuss them in detail
and when we see
these views and we're trying to
correlate to an established scientific
perspective we see that there's nothing
that is
of error there is there's nothing that
goes against established science so
let's take the gushing fluid as an
example
so
as we said
the the meaning here can mean that the
gushing fluid exits or is issued between
the backbone and the ribs or even the
loins in the ribs because remember sub
can mean
can mean backbone or loins in the ribs
and
if you think about it
the science says that 70 to 85 percent
which is the majority
um of the ejaculatory fluid that
contains sperm comes from the seminal
vesicles right and the similar vesicles
are between the backbone backbone or
loins and the ribs and remember the
backbone in arabic language includes the
tailbone bone or the coccyx so you can
see this picture here
where the tailbone is
you see
i don't know if you can see my arrow
here and you have the seminal vesicle
and this is the tailbone right
and above you have the ribs in the
collarbone
so between this area within this area is
actually the similar vesicles which are
responsible for the majority of the
gushing fluid right
now
this is this is very interesting this is
very interesting now
even if you don't
even if you don't accept this view
well the other linguistic meaning for
sun can mean loins which is this whole
area here
and it's true this whole area
and it
is the loins and above it is the ribs
and between it you have the seminal
vesicles which
produces 70 to 85 percent of the
ejaculatory fluid
that contains sperm
because the the sperm is
created in the testes
then it
basically travels up i think it travels
up this thing called the
the is it's the difference duct or
it's called
the vas deferens that's the one here
and so
when you see it from a linguistic
perspective which is a valid meaning in
the classical tradition
and it's within the hermeneutical
classical framework no problem
it's true that the gushing fluid comes
from between the backbone of the ribs or
specifically the loins and the ribs and
what's between the loins and the ribs
the vesicle the seminal vesicles which
are responsible for
most of the ejaculatory fluid now you
don't have to accept this view but even
if you were to accept this view
then
it doesn't go against established
science
now
please note that the reason many
scholars held that it is gushing fluid
that emerges from between the loins or
the backbone of the ribs
is because of a grammatical linguistic
rule and the linguistic rule is a
general rule is that the pronoun refers
to the closest preceding noun
however we have to understand that this
is not universally applied in the quran
okay
so but this is one of the reasons why
that was a majority view but it's not
the only view and we see
but before we go to the second view that
i've given you a few more um diagrams
here for you to see so you have the rib
cage here as you can see the blue line
and you have the end of the backbone
area because as you know linguistically
in arabic the backbone also includes the
tailbone
and
and this is the loin area as well so
that's another line because remember
sulph can also mean not only backbone
but the loin area and between these two
areas you have the seminal vesicles this
thing in green if you can see
okay the thing in green
and also if you want to have a close-up
again you see the seminar vesicle here
in green and you have the vas deferens
which takes the
sperm from the testes and i think it
goes to the seminal vesicles
and basically you have your full
full-blown ejaculatory fluid and most of
that comes from the summoner vesicle
which is around 70 to 85 percent of the
ejaculatory fluid
and as you can see this is the lauren
area
and remember the word sulphur can mean
backbone and the background does include
the tailbone as well but it also can
mean sub can also mean the loin area and
above is the rib and it's true that the
fluid
is emitted from between the loin or
backbone and the ribs so linguistically
and scientifically is not a problem at
all
so going to the second opinion
and the second opinion is actually the
baby that comes from between the loin
area as you can see here is the loin
area and up here is the ribs and this is
like the
the
this is not the ribs it's the sternum i
think it's called the sternum yeah
but the ribs around here so you have the
loin area and the ribs and the baby
emerges from this area so it's not a
problem at all so sulphur can mean
backbone and loin area and
can mean rib a rib cage and it's right
here and between this is the baby and it
emerges
from this area right emerges from
that area
so
this was the view of abdul haleem is the
view of abdul haleem and this is
something that could be classical
scholar and even
a classical scholar actually indicate
strongly that this is a valid view
that can be held because the language
allows it and the rules of tafsir of
jesus allow it to
so and one of the reasons why abdul
hadim also talks about this is because
he
argues that
it makes more sense with the kind of
imagery and the theme of the the the
chapter that these verses are in
and this chapter is this main theme is
about resurrection so you know allah
talks about that managed to reflect from
where he came from he came from a fluid
right
um a gushing fluid and then instead of
saying that it's this fluid that emerges
but rather what abdullah says is it this
should refer to the insane to the human
being it's the human being that emerges
from between the lowering area backbone
area and the ribs and then after there's
going to be resurrection so it makes
sense from a kind of chronological
thematic perspective that you started as
fluid then you became a baby then you
emerged and then you're gonna die and
you're gonna emerge again and you're
gonna be resurrected right so um abdul
haleem actually felt that this was more
in line with the conciseness and the
rhetorical nature of this chapter
so this is another valid view
the other view is as we mentioned is
basically sexual sexual intercourse
and this was a view that
talks about he doesn't
develop the view himself but he cites an
authority and basically the argument is
that
as a sub is a linguistic indicator it's
a kenya for a male
uh
it's a linguistic indicator for a female
so therefore those two things are
between between those two things is
where the ejaculation happens right
um and you know this is maybe a
rhetorical and
ethical or ethical or
linguistic has a linguistic etiquette
right the way to express uh this the you
know sexual activity uh in in in in the
quranic text which is you know and you
have these nuances in the quran you know
when allah talks about you know
when you touching a female right
and many of the
felt that this wasn't literally touching
with your hand but this was actually
intercourse itself so this is another
indicator you have things in the quad
and like to free a neck uh to free a
neck doesn't mean you just free the neck
on its own the apparent meaning is quite
obvious because what that means is it's
a kenya it's an indicator for the whole
human being in this context it's a slave
so to free a slave right
so this could be somewhat similar not
100 identical but these are it's a kenya
it's a linguistic indicator so uh
that is a indicator for the male a torah
is a linguistic indicate it's a canaa
for a female and it's between those two
entities where the gushing fluid happens
you know as a result of sexual
intercourse
um
that's another view it doesn't you don't
have to accept that view but if you were
to take that view which is a valid view
it doesn't go against scientific uh
consensus or any kind of established
science so we have a conclusion here the
three valley interpretations do not
contain scientific errors simple as that
and i'm shocked that this exists online
and you know there's no excuse anymore
because people need to be a little bit
more sincere and robust right
because we have
very good academic works in the english
language for example what i've
deliberately done for many of these
things although we do have arabic
references too
i've used an arabic classic quranic
classical arabic dictionary
that is in the english language
and it's it's about quranic usage and
i'll give you the full title at the end
and it's a phenomenal phenomenal
dictionary you look at the root word you
see the meanings of the root word and
you see
the different forms of the root word
um
in the quranic usage and it's really
really it's an amazing and amazing book
uh an amazing dictionary an amazing
resource and even you have things like
lane's lexicon which is in english as
well
and that is accessible online and you
could look into these things for
yourself you even have exegetical works
in english that are available as could
to be is available now maybe not all of
it but a lot of it you have ibn kether
albeit a summarized version but there's
no excuse anymore there's there's enough
out there for you to do your research
and not to just
you know cite
islamophobes and slight youtubers and
site people who don't have
you know
an in-depth understanding of the
religion or at least a kind of
decent understanding of the religion and
the quranic texts and the quranic
discourse and us
and the principles of exegesis and
hermeneutics
you know these things are
and by the way just because i'm talking
about this this doesn't make me an
expert
i i'm talking about this and it goes to
show how
not of an expert you need to be even to
understand these basic things because i
i'm not an expert i'm not a i'm not
qualified to do exegesis
but can i access dictionaries yes can i
understand them
yes can i
understand the verse and maybe dissect
it
yes for most of them so
you know and but that's that requires a
very basic level right so from that
perspective
um there's no excuse people people
should go and check things out for
themselves so this contention is
thoroughly debunked in my view
um
and uh and look and it's very and people
have i know you you guys have had
criticisms of why you've been speaking
about this gentleman yeah
um
but i think people misunderstand that
it's not really about him right because
he has what nearly three million
followers it's about the impact that
ignorance ignorance can make i used to
say this a lot you know it would
it take say you have a toddler a child
it's two years old and you're you're
you're nappy training diaper training
and they happen to excrete they
literally do a poo all over the carpet
floor in your living room
how long does it take them to do a poo
in on the carpet in the living room it
would take them about five minutes max
yeah
maybe less
how long does it take you to clean up
five hours at least
so you you can have someone who's
ignorant about the islamic tradition or
not bother to go a little bit deeper to
understand it they may have a lot of
followers and they literally do a poo on
the internet
and they do they excrete all over the
internet and you know it takes ages
sometimes to contact all the individuals
that have been affected because we live
in a really ridiculous world that people
just like follow influences
so and you know i i wanted to mention
this because i didn't want people to
point fingers at you that you think that
you know
um
that you're dealing with someone that's
not worth dealing with
no
it's not about the person really may
allah guide him you know it would be
good to have a conversation with him one
day you know you could give him my
number we could have a chat um and you
know we could really connect and
understand his context or where he's
coming from and trying to you know
help him you know
to get the optimal version of him and
maybe he could do that with me too and
then i think in the end it would be
beneficial for both parties we should
give him dawah because you know this is
a true sign of a believer that you love
for others what you love for yourself
and from the perspective of giving dawah
and to non-muslims is that you want
goodness for them you want guidance for
them yeah
this is something that now he speaks
about the classical scholar
and even uh the maliki's i think he was
a maliki scholar
so muslims should have this overwhelming
mercy and they want to they they have
this loving kindness with people because
they want them to have have goodness and
guidance yeah in other words they
we should be committed to people's
well-being so you know that should
happen
and
but
he's got influence if you've got like
three million subs you know and
you make a mess all over the carpet
floor you know from a metaphorical
perspective it would take a long time to
clean up and that's what we have to
produce things like this because he has
other objectives right i thought i'll
just mention that anyway any questions
guys any any points that you want to
improve on add anything
so i just want to quickly summarize um
your microphone bro
yeah mike is it low
i think it switched though
okay how about how about now that's good
that's good yeah okay so before there
was an echo so i had to play with my mic
settings and mute it so that stopped so
exactly for the people that called that
out that was my fault so i just want to
kind of elaborate or summarize what i
gathered from
your uh explanation of these verses so
first they want to go back to the verses
themselves
lost allah says in the quran
let people then consider what they were
created from created from a spurting
fluid stemming from between the backbone
and the rib cage so firstly
that fluid itself doesn't necessarily
mean sperm but everything that is
that spurts out during uh climax
for i guess for a man and that is not
just sperm itself but
you know fluid that is that comes from
the seminal vesicle so if you were to
interpret stemming from between the
backbone of the rib cage as being the
man's backbone and the man's rib cage
then that interpretation would be valid
and scientifically um accurate as well
is that correct yes because the seminar
vesicles
are between that area and they produce
around 70 to 85 percent of the
ejaculatory fluid perfect
and then now something may be very
specific they may like oh but the
backbone is not really is you know
the ribs are not really between
uh the backbone uh sorry the sum of the
vessels are not really between the
backbone and the ribs because if you
make a line between
the tailbone which in arabic includes
the backbone right in terms of the
meaning and you and which is right next
to or parallel to
um the seminal vesicles if you draw a
line right up it won't hit the rib cage
you'll go out of his belly because i
mean they'll be like oh it's not really
between i find that really stupid
because it's like saying you know just
because my head is not
literally in between my shoulders we
can't say my head is not between my
shoulders it is between my shoulders
it's not literally between my shoulders
because this is my head my shoulders are
here right so if if you draw a line
between my shoulders is is my collar
bone it's not my head but we have the
saying
your head is between your shoulders
right
now uh so that's how you can respond to
that view oh the way to respond it is
well
you know a son doesn't only mean
backbone you also mean loins and that
now you have a greater area you have the
area where you you know whatever you put
your briefs on or your underwear on
that's that's that's the that's the loin
area and between that
uh between that and the the
the the breastbone or the ribs is
actually the seminal vesicles
and everything else that is necessary in
order for you to
you know
in order for the ejaculatory fluid to
exit from
the body
okay okay perfect
and just to reiterate for the viewers uh
if my mic is still low just let me know
i'm playing around with it inshallah i'm
gonna try and keep myself muted so
there's no echo so
that is if the backbone in the ribs
refers to the backbone of the man in the
ribs of the woman
so next if you take the approach that
it's the backbone of the man in the ribs
of the woman
then that would also be a
an accurate interpretation according to
the quran and according to science
because it would be referring to
you know
kind of conception and uh intercourse
itself in the act of it
and that is a valid interpretation that
some classical scholars have had and
then the third interpretation would be
that it's referring to that that was the
third interpretation so in terms of the
chronology of what i what i was speaking
about but so
uh
is a linguistic indicator for the male
it means backbone but it's an indicator
for the mill and
is a linguistic indicator for the female
so and that means ribcage but if you
even see them as a backbone in a very
rib cage right uh and the backbone is
the male and the ribcage is the female
then in between the eyes basically what
happens and you know you have the
ejaculatory fluid as a result of sexual
intercourse
um
now the third view that you were going
to mention which is the second view this
was about the baby emerging between the
backbone and the ribs and this refers to
the backbone of the ribs of the woman
which is one of the valid views in the
islamic tradition
so it could mean the backbone of the
woman and the ribs or the women or the
loins of the woman and the ribs of the
woman and that's where the womb is and
the baby emerges from the womb
makes sense 100 100 and i think that and
this is what's very important to
understand
we're not making this stuff up yeah
we're not we're not like trying to do
linguistic gymnastics this is based on
classical scholars
that did not have the internet and did
not meet people that had these
ridiculous contentions yeah
they so this was this predates the kind
of discourse on scientific errors yeah
and this is why it's very important to
highlight that because this we are
standing on the shoulders of giants our
classical tradition have given us all of
these answers which is amazing yeah
and that's why i could be classical
and they said that it's linguistically
sound to
think that this is the baby coming out
of the womb and the womb is between the
backbone or the loins and the ribs of
the woman
and this is
perfectly fine within the rules of the
classical arabic language within the
rules of the tafsir exegesis and it's
one of the valid interpretations and
meanings
100 so it kind of seems like to make the
argument that this verse is
scientifically inaccurate you would have
to first misrepresent what is being
stated
and um yeah and maybe even in some cases
misrepresent what uh the standard you
know narrative in science is at the same
time
so
i think yes and if you if you want to
claim the quran is inaccurate in this
case you have to show
that all the possible interpretations
and valid meanings of this verse in
these words
are actually they actually go against
established science and we've given you
just three i think there are more
three of them
clearly show that they're not against
established science therefore
your contention is basis
100 all right so i'm gonna
i'm gonna put a brief pause for the
viewers here and i'm going to maybe you
know what maybe we should just do all of
them and then we could talk about
principles it might be better now
because if we go back and we go through
the whole
presentation about principles the
epistemic goals of the quran
the timeless nature of the quran and
then come back to this i think would be
a lot it would be quite heavy maybe we
should just cover all of his issues
all of the responses to the issues then
we go and we could if we have time we
could go through this we're gonna we're
gonna be back in like 20 to 30 seconds
guys it's gonna put a short break
all right
for everyone who sent the super chats
and also just for you guys knowledge um
the laptop speakers i can't turn them
down because i have a specific plug-in
and sometimes my mic is unmuted it'll
pick up the sound from my laptop so when
the brothers are talking you'll hear it
through my mic so i just have to myself
so thank you guys for calling that out
and i think we're good to continue here
inshallah
we need a producer bro for real yeah
yeah i know
so let's just you gonna bring up the
clip for this one or
uh
yeah yeah i could play quickly
yeah all right
all right and uh hamza which one are you
talking about now i don't know if it's
an order of uh this is the
sex reproduction
everything is created in pairs all right
all right yeah i think that's next up
all right
genders are what they do not know
what is this saying
he's saying that all living creatures
come
in a pier
of sexes male and female
what does that mean
that means that there can be no
organisms no species on the planet that
are asexual that are
genderless or only have come in one
gender
all right so i think that's good enough
so basically what he says is that allah
says in the quran and this is his own
inference based on whatever translation
he's reading where he says that allah
says no quran all living things are
created in pairs meaning
genders of two male and female which
means and he said these words there can
be no living organism that has only one
gender then he goes on to mention i
think like a whip tail is it or
something like that which is only female
and uh certain bacteria and and so on
and so forth
yeah so this is a form of what you call
isogesis
isogenesis is used exegesis is you you
get an interpretation from the text
isages is that you bring an
interpretation you squeeze it into the
text yeah
so
uh
i just know it's a typo on the on the
title no problem um so that's this is
the form of isa jesus so the verse that
he's referring to is chapter 36 verse 36
um
which is quite interesting actually
because this verse talks about pears
right and then you have chapter 36 verse
36 it's like a double anyway
the point here is allah says in the
quran glory be to him who created all
the pairs
of things that the earth produced as one
of them as well as themselves and other
things they do not know about and this
is the contention the answer is that all
living things come in pairs of sexes
male and female that means no organism
is created without despair meaning the
pair of a male and a female however
asexual reproduction is a biological
fact therefore the quran contains
scientific error and this is nonsense
yeah
here's the first answer the first thing
that we need to understand is the quran
does not mention that all quick things
are created as a result of a sexual
prayer the verse doesn't say that at all
you've read that into the verse yeah
although there have been interpretations
that are quite similar but the verse
itself from a primary facey reading if
you read it just like normally
it doesn't say that all things are
created as a result of a sexual pair
meaning
male and a female
it simply mentions that all things that
create that are created have a pair or
an opposite or based on two things
connected in some way and you can
understand this further when we go to
the root word so the conclusion is first
and foremost this contention is a
misreading of the verse it's like a
straw man isn't it so you misrepresent
someone's argument and you just hack
that and you attack that argument well
you're not really dealing with with our
argument in this context you're not
really dealing with what the verse is
saying that says not the verse is not
saying that all things are created as a
result of a sexual pair right
now
before we unpack that further let's go
to this second answer
and
the thing we need to understand is this
even if the crowd were referring to the
view that all created things are created
as a result of a male and a female it
still does not imply a scientific error
and there's something very important to
understand
because in the arabic language
when you use the word
and allah uses the word
yeah every or all which is the normal
general meaning
this this this
this
word doesn't just mean every single
thing it could mean a lot of
and we see it when we study the root of
this word the root of this word is kaf
and it means everything
a lot or many of those things or many
things right
and this is well known in the arabic
language that kul here means many or a
lot and this is even self-evident in the
quran when allah says in chapter 7 verse
149 we inscribed everything
yeah for him in the tablets which taught
and explained everything
now the when allah says that um
he mentions coolly everything in moses
tablets
and that these tablets explained
everything not one muslim is going to
claim that moses tabis included
descriptions of birani rice or how to
make samosas right
you know no one's going to say that
you know it doesn't it probably doesn't
include anything about how to do dna
tests and it does probably doesn't talk
about the epistemology of i don't know
of testimony or whatever the point here
is
uh clearly in this context does not mean
every single thing it could be many
things or
many things that are relevant in this
case right but the the point here is we
have a quranic intertextual analysis for
like intertextual you're you're going
from one part of the book one verses and
one surah to other verse and other surah
to have a more holistic understanding of
the particular usage of the word and we
could see the usage of this word can
mean everything but it can also mean a
lot or many things and we know
asexual reproduction is not the norm
it's actually sexual reproduction is the
norm then you have a sexual pair a male
and a female it is it is a deviation
from the normal flake of having asexual
reproduction but allah if you were to
take this view
take the view of the person's eyes to
jesus reading into the quran if you were
to take the view that is to do with
things that are created require sexual
power man and a female all things
um if you take could mean many things or
a lot of then it's true there are a lot
of things that require sexual pain
so it's not scientifically inaccurate
it's actually not a problem
and just to elaborate further look the
arabic usage of the word could is
similar in the english language right
you know when we say things like all of
my money is gone or all my money is lost
that means a lot of my money is lost
because you may have still one pound
left right or when i say all of my
energy is used up well that's not
technically true because you won't be
able to say all my energy is used up if
really all of your energy was used up
because using energy to say all my
energy is used up right because you
still got energy to talk it means most
of or a lot of my energy right
and so the conclusion here is this
contention displays an ignorance of the
linguistic nuances of the word could
simple as that so it's not a scientific
error even if his understanding is
correct it's still not a scientific
error
let's go to answer three
so the word that allah uses here
as where comes from the rule
and it has the following meanings
even number pair double two things which
are connected in some way one of a pair
species type and it also means to cause
trouble
now al isfahani and other scholars they
explained that this had nothing to do
with sexual reproduction this had to do
with the duality of create things they
used this verse to prove absolute
monotheism
because
the argument is that allah is free of
duality he is
ahad he is uniquely one as as allah says
in the quran in chapter 112
uniquely one allah is free of any
duality right from that perspective he's
uniquely one
so the argument was basically in order
to understand the existence of any
creative thing there's always going to
be a duality
even if some things are without an
opposite or a pair they are composed of
an inherent duality here's an example an
illustrative example say for example you
have a single rock a single rock doesn't
have a paired partner right however a
single rock contains the duality of its
substance which is the stone
and the form which is the shape
right which make which makes which make
the rock right which make it the rock
so from that perspective you know things
have duality or they have and
two things are connected in some way
there are there are things that have
opposites
um and there's been a massive discussion
in the classical tradition i don't have
to go to all the different uh
kind of discussions based on this
concept but in essence
all creative things have an inherent
duality even if that thing is alone
such as a rock yeah the inherent duality
would be basically of its substance
which is a stone and the form which is
its shape which make it the rock
so you know which was very interesting
the classical scholars use this verse
from a logical perspective try and prove
uh monotheism
um and uh you know today some people are
thinking that this is to do with science
yeah
um but it's more to do with logic than
science if you think about more to do
with you know sound reasoning so the
conclusion here is this verse
can refer to duality and not sexual
reproduction
and the discussions on duality are
transcend science because they're
metaphysical in nature and science
generally speaking can't deal with these
metaphysical ideas because it has to
adopt metaphysical ideas and look for
science to to progress for example
science has a metaphysical assumption of
external causal connections of a
particular notion of causality for
instance yeah or that external causal
connections exist another philosophical
assumption that science has that is that
nature is uniform if they if scientists
or philosophers or science never adopted
that assumption you would never be able
to claim that well-confirmed theories
can explain all the phenomena that it's
supposed to address right
so
um yeah that's another view
so when we take each of these three
views
the
it's it's a misplaced contention again
number one uh you know it doesn't say
that all create things as a result of a
sex repair a main and a female it just
simply simply says that all create
things have a pair on opposite or based
on two things connected into in in some
way as we refer to uh on the
understanding of the root word that we
mentioned just a few moments ago so this
contention and misreading of the verse
even if the reading of the verse is
accurate it doesn't imply a scientific
error because allah measures in the
quran here
comes from the word kul which means
every or all but we know if you study
the root of this word kaf lam lam it
means everything a lot
many things right and so allah is saying
can allah can be and this is
linguistically viable from the rules of
exegesis and the arabic grammar the
classical arabic uh
uh language that you could that could
hear in this context can mean
allah created many things with pairs
right and even if you believe this
refers to sexual reproduction it could
it could mean that allah
created many things that have a sexual
pair male and a female no problem
it's not saying all so for you to find
to say oh look you know
uh there is asexual uh reproduction
going on uh therefore this verse is
wrong no because the word kul here or
can actually mean not everything it
could mean or it could mean many things
or a lot
um and finally as we just mentioned if
you look at the root word and many of
the scholars the classical scholars
never even saw this as to do with
anything with sexual reproduction it was
to do with
um duality and allah is free of duality
he is uniquely one all created things
have an inherent duality in them
um and yeah so again
case closed this is
feel like i was just here for like moral
support
no bro you know what next time you
should do this presentation because i
really believe with your voice
it would put everyone asleep it would
enhance the communicative communicative
effect man your voice just enhances
everything bro you could talk about
carpet cleaner and everyone would enjoy
it
yeah they got enjoyed in their dreams
bro
while they're listening to me
hey man i bless you man i know it's late
there bro
and once we figure that out inshaallah
all three of us me rami and angel will
be there inshallah maybe two times a
week for you know regular live streams
once we figure it out you guys will be
the first to know but uh thank you for
your time bro
yes
brother good talking to you again
and uh my love bless you for everything
you do well
honestly
yeah very clear very concise i think
just a very general way to summarize it
is that the word kul does not mean every
single thing and it just could mean many
things so many of the living things were
created in paris and that would not be
an inaccurate statement to make
obviously it's a lot deeper for that but
for anyone who feels a little lost if
there's anyone who does
um that's basically a
very very very reductionist
articulation of what sheikh hamza sorry
protein
hamza just presented to us
i know i could share these slides with
people as well anyway right um
i could send them to you and you guys
could share with your audiences and show
that they could
download the function of the mountains i
think that is a very interesting one so
i'm going to pull that up and play this
is it
and guys please smash that like button
so this video hits more hearts
reaches more people gives them more
knowledge that's all we ask
all right so i'm going to pull up 326
15.
lizard that's female only species and
bacteria that is genderless
oh but then there's death
[Music]
but then there's this surah 16 verse 15
he had placed in the earth firm
mountains so it does not shake with you
as well as river rivers and pathways so
you may find your way
what is he saying
that
earth that mountains prevent earthquakes
there are pegs
that stabilize the earth without which
there would be no earthquakes
however
that is not the cause of earthquakes and
this is something i actually thought
about recently and uh if you tune into
my podcast i was asking questions about
this as well
however
in through exploration we came to the
conclusion that tectonic plates are real
all you got to do is look at the mariana
trench
all you gotta do is look at the mariana
trench
and we know that earthquakes are formed
by tectonic plates being pushed together
and sending them up
this this movement of the tectonic
plates that cause earth is what causes
earthquakes what am i saying if there
were no tectonic plates
there would be no mountains
if there were no m there would be no the
same thing that causes mountains is the
same thing that causes earthquakes you
trying to say that earthquake mountains
prevent earthquakes
some may add no how did i get this wrong
okay so this argument is basically he's
stating that allah is saying in the
quran and i'm basically using his words
here and putting it onto the quran while
the verse is here so he's basically
saying that allah says in the quran that
he has put
mountains on the earth so that basically
prevents or or limits earthquakes
and then he says tectonic plates
are what causes earthquakes and they're
also the same thing that causes
mountains so the same thing that caused
mountains cause earthquakes how would
that even make sense
yes yes so he also mentions
uh mines have pegs i believe as well so
he didn't refer to the verse but i've
put it here anyway when allah says in
chapter 78 and make the mountains to
keep it stable or
the mountains as pegs
now there's an interesting thing here so
let's first summarize the contention the
quran says that the mountains have pegs
that stabilize earth and prevent
earthquakes however they do not and
earthquakes are not caused by having no
mountains
the first thing we need to understand is
what the quran does not mention how
earthquakes are formed in this verse and
it does not say that mountains prevent
earthquakes from occurring
it doesn't really say that allah says
that
it that the earth doesn't shake or sway
now you could infer that may mean an
earthquake but the quran itself mentions
earthquakes
many times that it decimated societies
in the past for example quran 29 37
and you know the the verse mentions that
the earth will not shake or sway not
necessarily there'll be no earthquakes
there is a subtle difference so that
needs to be needs to be understood
because
you know
you he there is a conflation or
misreading here there's a conflation
between
earthquakes occurring and
the
the earth not swaying or shaking
now so from that perspective you can see
that this is a misreading of the verse
you've done on the ice to jesus you've
read into the verse you don't allow the
verse to read to you if you like yeah
and you read into it you're thinking
this must mean earthquakes and this must
mean this is how earthquakes are formed
well the quran doesn't mention that at
all allah just basically says
that the mountains uh they stand firm
the earth to prevent it shaking under
you that's it
the rest of what you're doing is now an
isages you're reading into the text
unnecessarily
but let's let's go to another answer
well let's assume that it is earthquakes
what's very interesting
modern science 2020
and
um
in two specific papers that i've cited
here
actually shows
that earthquake that mountains reduce
the harm and impact of earthquakes
in a study published in 2020 sun safa
and ellis conducted computer simulations
and discovered that undersea mountains
weakened earthquakes
and this study was published in the
journal in in the journal nature
geoscience
also you had ma archuleta and paige
conducted a study on the san gabriel
mountains in its relation to los angeles
and they found that when an earthquake
occurs the san gabriel mountains reduce
its intensity by up to 50 percent
they concluded that the san gabriel
mountains act as a shield for los
angeles reducing seismic excitations
from earthquakes
so you have some science here
i'm not saying this is fully conclusive
but you have some signs here that's
indicating that actually mountains do
reduce earthquakes
yeah
now there are more robust answers in my
view yeah but before we get into that
let's talk about the the pegs here
because he also mentioned pegs so let's
let's unpack that as well so in the
quran chapter 76 allah says and make the
mountains to keep it stable and the
mountain all another translation the
mountains as pegs
so the relevant word here is
okay now the root of this word is
and it has the following meanings peg
pin stake to firmly fix and to be firmly
established
so i don't know why they were dismissing
this as as wrong because at the end of
the day this is well known now in in
geology that mountains have roots if you
pick a normal geology book i have one i
think it's in the office and it's on
like a geology and it talks about it has
it has a subheading that says do
mountains have roots and it explains why
mountains have roots yeah this is well
known in geology now
and by the way is the author a
non-muslim
yeah
yeah for sure
and
and not only that
the the roots the mountains help the
mountain stay up and last a long time
please note what does allah say the
words uh altad mean it comes from wow
then it could mean to fix firmly to be
firmly established so the roots of the
mountains
uh firmly establish the mountains in
terms of that they they could stay up
and they last a long time and there are
ample references in the literature i
just picked one from online but there's
many many more in many books yeah and
one example i picked was
once plain plate tectonic processes
build up build a mountain range the the
buoyant underlying route enables the
mountain range to hang around a long
time even while it's being actively
eroded
so and remember firmly established if
you take this word to mean fermi
establishes one of its valid meanings
the mountains
are firmly established because of its
uh
because of its roots if you like here
and so the the the mountains are firmly
established
and the reason the family established
because they have roots and the roots
are have a function
to keep the mountains up and to keep
them going for a long time
so
the valid meaning of altar doesn't have
to be peg because he dismissed it as all
what does this mean
it could also mean firmly established
and we know
that mountains have roots that firmly
establish the mountains and this is well
known in geology yeah to go to any
reference
answer number four i like this one this
one is trans historical meaning
well
kind of trans-historical from the point
of view that you don't need any science
to actually try and justify this because
a valid classical and modern
interpretation of chapter 16 verse 15 is
that this refers to the creation of the
earth and the role of the formation of
the mountains during that time meaning
the time when the earth was created like
i think is about four billion years ago
and this was before the existence of
humanity and is connected to another
verse in quran 49 9 10 and that
classical exegetes they actually connect
1615 to 49 9 10 which talks about the
creation of the earth so and one view
amongst various views on this issue
states that the earth was shaking or
swaying it had instability when it was
forming when it was becoming earth right
when earth was becoming what we see
today it had a shaking or swaying had
instability
and the formation of the mountains at
that time helped stop the swaying or
shaking
now this view is not against established
science why because science cannot
confirm or reject this really with any
conclusivity
because it was like four billion years
ago
so it's very very it's almost
impossible to claim with any scientific
certainty that this view is an
unscientific view
so and this is a valid interpretation
it's actually this is what the
interpretation of the salaf the pious
predecessors right
so here's a chronological list of
scholars who held disputes not
exhaustive but here's a chronological
order yeah
you have
bin
right i think it was sahabi yeah
you had hasan al-basri
the famous scholar you had you have
abdul razak 200 years after
it being
the famous classical exegete right
you had al-sharawi
you have a sabuni right
and you know
you have a whole list of scholars from
the first three generations the best
generations to have lived
um
to have lived amongst the muslims this
is the son of the pious predecessors are
spiritual masters if you like yeah
they had the view that this was about
the early formation of the earth it's
not about now it's about the early
formation of the earth because when the
earth was forming and developing into
the earth that is today the the earth
was swaying or shaking and the
formations of mountains during that
period
actually stop the swaying or shaking
prior to the existence of human of the
existence of humanity
um and this is kind of
trans scientific if you like it
transcends science from the point of
view that the science cannot with any
kind of
conclusive evidence go against this
point
um
so yeah so based on this contention uh
based on based on this this contention
is misplaced it the verse does not refer
to earthquakes in the present rather
refers to the stabilizing function
mountains had in the early development
of the earth as a planet before animals
and humans existed and i've given you a
bunch of references many references here
for you to look at so the conclusion is
this the valid interpretation is not at
odds with the scientific understanding
and as we said the scientific error
narrative would only work if they could
show that all the valid meanings and
interpretations are actually going
against established science or if there
is only one interpretation that that
interpretation in yourself is going
against valid science and you can't do
that with this at all especially when
you look at the fourth answer
so there's nothing wrong with the uh
with the quranic usage of the word altar
or that could mean peg or firmly fixed
or firmly established because we know
mountains are family established and lo
and behold they have roots and those
roots are responsible to keep the
mountains where they are and to keep
them going for a long time in other
words firmly fixed firmly established
also chapter
16 verse 15 when the mountains are
supposed to you know not
prevent shaking uh or stop
the earth from swaying or shaking we
actually see this in the scientific
literature that mountains actually
reduce even by 50
the kind of seismic impact of earthquake
of earthquakes
um
and also if you take the
the view of some of the pious
predecessors that this has nothing to do
with the the mountains functions now
or even earthquakes now it was to do
with the early formation of the earth
because the scholars linked this to
chapter 49 verse 9 to 10 which is
talking about the formation of the earth
and during that time there was swaying
and shaking of the earth
you know one could imagine maybe some
kind of top layer whatever the case may
be and the initial mountains that were
formed actually uh stabilized the earth
in order for subsequent animals and
humans many many years after to be able
to live you know and functionally live
as as a species on on planet earth
this cannot be denied categorically by
science or even affirmed
and therefore it's not a scientific
error by virtue of that so from that
perspective um this valid interpretation
is not at odds with the scientific
anything that's established
scientifically
so uh again it's a misreading it's a
misunderstanding there are many
different valid interpretations based on
the language and based on the classical
exegetical tradition
yeah 100 uh multiple interpretations
again all of which uh do not go against
well i was going to say standard
scientific narrative but there is not
really a standard scientific narrative
with this because like you mentioned
there's nothing that we can really say
definitively on this matter so even the
original contention is something that
falls short from a scientific
perspective and science is something
that falls short i guess from a
philosophical perspective which i think
you will get into um
i appreciate that you're going through
all the possible different
interpretations too you're not just
giving one and reducing it and limiting
it to that yeah because we have to be
just and knew it so we have to allow the
quran to speak for itself and we have to
allow the tradition to speak for itself
and
you know when we do that we're always
going to have answers because we're
standing on the shoulders of giants
100 very beautifully said
before we move on i think there's two
more there's the birds what you have on
screen birds uh flying and what what
makes them fly what holds them up and
then the splitting of the moon before
that yeah there's a lot of people
in the chat who are saying things that
go don is live and he's blocking people
who comments the three muslims and allah
good bro he's not talking about us he's
not talking about islam he's doing his
own thing reacting to other news um
leave him alone we're not here to to you
know talk about how horrible don is or
how bad he is or how dumb he is
we're not saying any of these things all
we're doing is taking the things that he
claimed in ignorance and we're
dismantling them to show that they have
no bearing in truth
scientific philosophical quranic
a religious even no matter what it is
that he's claiming it's not something
that holds and that's what we're trying
to show so nobody go to his stream and
comment whatever if you want to watch
him and watch him react to sneak one or
whatever go do that but don't comment
anything about us don't assault him
don't bash him it's not something that
the prophet peace and blessings be upon
him taught us to do
and inshallah
when people reach out to people like
this just just just have rahma have
mercy have
you know look at uh
the musa salaam was taught by allah to
speak
softly to pharaoh pharaoh was the most
the worst tyrant
and al-quran comments on this and says
you know if musa alayhi islam speak to
firaoun pharaoh
softly
then imagine how we must speak to
everybody else
as one scholars i think said once
you're not a moses and the person you're
talking to is not a pharaoh
yes yes so we need to chill out a bit
this is not an ego game
um and we need to basically you know
reach out to them i would even tell the
guys you know give give the the
gentleman my number we'll have a private
chat nothing has to be public
i really believe that people who find
religion
it could be a means for them to find the
final religion and the true religion of
allah people go through that journey how
many people have gone for christianity
and buddhism because they're looking for
something we're living in a in a world
where there is a spiritual vacuum yeah
we live in in an age of narcissism of
excessive individualism right you know
we don't even we don't even know how to
love anymore all right because we don't
see other we don't see anyone else other
than our own selves everyone is a
projection of our own of ourselves and
we just end up loving ourselves not
loving the other human being
and so we live in that type of
individualistic narcissistic society
which has affected the dao as well
unfortunately
and people are getting affected and it's
materialistic as well
and people are looking for some greater
meaning
they want a narrative they want a
philosophy they want a world view that
can
explain reality explain life explain
suffering
and the only worldview that does that
adequately is islam and not only does it
do it adequately but it's also based on
a strong intellectual foundation that is
true
and it has obviously
a a worldview a deen
a
a lens that you point your eyes that you
could see clearly and see reality for
what it is
where you
are in your life
uh who you're supposed to worship and
why you're supposed to worship him and
that's allah
so we need to reach out to these people
man we need we need to we shouldn't do
it in a way that's egocentric or
egotistical or it's about i just want to
win yeah because the day the one who
calls
is is is a refined character
because it doesn't doesn't
doesn't just obey his nafs his ego
because the nature of the ego is i
always want to be right i never want to
be wrong i always want to look good i
always want to impose to the degree that
i give up the truth or give up the right
way of doing things
and sometimes our excessive need which
comes from a weakness really is a space
of place of weakness that you just want
to prove people wrong and show how wrong
they are all the time
even though the way you're doing it and
and the reason you're doing it and your
approach you're taking
is going against the truth islamic
ethics and is is going against the right
way of doing things
um then then that's very dangerous we
need to give the up we need to really
really focus on the goal here which is
really allah's pleasure and that's we
should always ask ourselves a question
what does allah want from me in this
particular context rather change the
question
what is closer to the optimal pleasure
of allah in this context
what is more pleasing to allah and that
means you have to find out what the
context is you have to find out who you
are how you should relate to the
situation how you should relate to the
person you have to find out is it the
right time the right place the right
context you have to have wisdom
and so on and so forth so you have to
assess the situation for it for itself
so ask yourself the question is it the
right thing to do to go on someone
else's live stream and start saying that
oh why don't you come on when you debate
you're an idiot blah blah is that
conducive to what is more pleasing to
allah i don't think so
so that's we need to ask ourselves those
questions what is most pleasing to allah
in this particular context with the
moral variables that i have
and god that was beautifully said
and guys if you want to embody that
sincerely make dua redund and not just
dance niko and all these other youtubers
too make dwell that they're guided you
know yesterday me um
rami and angel we were on on the phone
with sheikh bhattaslim and it was a
private call but i'm sure you know he
won't mind us sharing this but he gave
us an analogy he said that if someone
has dirt in their hand right and you
basically call out the dirt and you only
focus on that dirt that they're holding
they're just going to grip and firmly
grasp onto that dirt even harder however
show them this diamond or this gem
something else eventually they'll want
to let go of that dirt all together
and that's within their fitrah the
innate disposition allah has created
every single human being with this
innate primordial original state
that you know
is is like a vehicle that is driving
itself towards the hut towards the truth
that allah exists that is worthy of
worship
and
sometimes that vehicle gets clouded and
our job is to uncloud that vehicle that
that windscreen in order for the vehicle
to direct itself towards the truth
everyone has that within them so
everyone has that diamond within them
the fitra we just need to make them
realize that but sometimes there's a bit
of dust there's a bit of soil on on that
diamond we need to help them clean it
not to point at the dust fad's right
and and that's what we're missing you
know um don't get me wrong there's times
to be assertive but if you're always
assertive and aggressive and always want
to be egocentric and egotistical and
except and an exhibitionist right if you
always want to do that
then that actually shows that you you're
weak you don't have courage
because courage is to do the right thing
in the right time in the right way
considering the context that's courage
and that that's difficult
you know
let's move on to 1679.
all right inshaallah um
i guess i'll play it's fairly quick
and it's right here
birds flying in the air and being held
up without the flapping of the wings
you've all seen it a bird just gliding
in the air
allah is the one that holds it up
it is a miracle of a law
while dwight uh the the birds are in the
air suspended in the air
now you might say
well no actually technically don uh
allah created the air and he created the
laws of physics and he created you know
um you know aerodynamics so what this
verse is really saying is that uh uh um
what it's really saying is is be
technically everything that causes the
the bird to stay afloat is a result of
allah's creation and that's what he was
saying he wasn't saying that he was
holding the bird up with some kind of
invisible magical force
but by that logic everything is a
miracle
by that logic then i could say oh behold
this car that stays firmly planted on
the ground on the street it doesn't
float up into the sky
a magical force holds it down to the
earth
gravity gravity
all right so
again he just makes the argument that
you know allah says in the quran that no
or none hold the birds up when they're
flying except allah and he's like even
if a person said that while allah
created you know the laws of physics and
aerodynamics and and the bird and so on
and so forth um he can make the argument
that you know anything is a miracle
because look you know i'm sitting here
in my chair i'm not floating away a car
is not floating up it's planted on the
ground and kind of just making a mockery
of it that's his whole argument
yes yes so
look in quran 1679 allah says do they
not see the birds made to fly through
the air in the sky nothing holds them
except god and allah that truly are
signs and this for those who believe so
the contention is
the quran says that it's only
birds fly in the sky this is wrong as we
know it is air pressure right
so there's a few things that and so
usually these detractors
are in the beginning for some people who
are not maybe
understand the context they might think
oh this sounds a bit
true
it has some weight to this
but it only has some way only if they
reduce the quran to one verse
and they don't have a holistic
understanding of the quran
and they don't understand the key
quranic messages
so a key answer here is is that the
quran is making two points that are not
unscientific
they're not because they're not
scientific that's the point to make
because they are metaphysical
allah is making a kind of theo
philosophical point
about
the causality of creation or primary
ultimate causes and natural causality
secondary causes
and we see this in the quran and by the
way
you cannot claim that this is a
scientific era because this is about
causality and causality even in western
philosophy is under the kind of domain
of knowledge of metaphysics yeah
this is a metaphysical discussion the
nature of cause and effect the nature of
the causal link science can't deal with
that because this is a metaphysical
discussion science can observe effects
and causes but it doesn't observe the
nature of the causal link it actually
has to assume a particular metaphysical
position on the nature of the causal
link
so the point we need to understand very
clear here is this is not a scientific
point allah is making
allah is making a metaphysical point or
kind of first principles point
that is not
that is not scientific and therefore it
can't be unscientific because this this
this this is prior to any science
because science requires an
understanding of causality for it to
even work anyway
so what allah is trying to talk to us
here about and elsewhere in the quran
that allah is talking about the
causative creation or you call this the
primary ultimate cause and natural
causality or secondary causes right so
the ultimate cause for everything in the
universe on earth and what's in it is
allah is god yeah
and the natural or secondary causes are
what god has created such as the natural
forces let me give you an illustration
a carpenter makes a wooden chair
even though he used the saw hammer
screws etc he is the one who made the
chair no one would say
it is the hammer and the soul that made
the chair
the carpet is the primary cause for the
wooden chair and the tools were the
secondary causes that were used by the
carpenter
and what's very important to understand
is that the quran accepts secondary
natural causes for example the rain what
does allah say in chapter 16 verse
65 it is allah who sends water down from
the sky and with it revives the earth
when it is dead
from a primary cause point of view it is
allah who revives the earth when it is
dead
but from a secondary cause point of view
a natural cause point of view is
actually the rain that revives the earth
when it's dead those two things are not
mutually exclusive
allah is giving us a distinction on how
to understand reality because these
things in the quran are there to stop
polytheism argue against polytheism and
argue for monotheism
so
the quran is also telling us that is
allah who sustains everything that
exists from moment to moment consider
someone blowing on a whistle yeah and
make sounds
if the person stopped blowing the sounds
would stop
the person must continue blowing the
whistle
in a similar but not analogous way
because we can't make analogies with
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
we don't make analogies but in a similar
kind of
fashion or by greater reason the birds
have been created by allah he also
created the air and the natural forces
at play
and maintains all of them and if he
stopped maintaining them they would
cease to exist and function that's what
allah is trying to say
and allah is not saying that there are
no natural causes for the bird to fly
because allah mentions elsewhere in the
quran it refers to natural causes such
as the rain and so on and so forth
allah is making a wider
point that ultimately
allah is the primary creator cause for
everything and he maintains and sustains
everything this is actually a key aspect
of the feed of
the tawheed of allah's creative agency
allah's creative power
and
just because allah is mentioning that he
is the primary he's the make the
ultimate maintainer and he's the primary
cause or creator for all of these things
it doesn't exclude the fact that these
natural causes actually exist as well
right
so allah here is making a point about
who is the
the ultimate maintenance maintainer of
this who is the cause the ultimate cause
of this and it's allah that is the point
allah is making and you could only
understand that if you read the whole of
the quran and you connect all of these
verses together
if you have a reductionist approach
you're not going to understand the quran
and you're going to have missed place
contentions so in conclusion the
contention is a misunderstanding of the
verse and the and misunderstanding the
quran's presentation of causality and
god's creative power in other words
all right fight i'll let you do a recap
of that one since i had to take a five
minute break
bro
i gotta go what
yeah
listen listen listen um
well
here's the thing long story short and
i'll make it simple for for people that
kind of lost it or even for your brother
or
but there's and as he was saying this i
was i was envisioning like a lowercase c
and an uppercase c cause right so in the
causal chain of events right allah is
still like big c creator the cause right
but there's still little things that can
can help you create other things so for
example
was talking about how you know let's say
if if a carpenter uses a
hammer and some other things to build a
chair right you can't go around saying
that the primary cause of the chair was
the hammer you could say it's a
secondary cause or a tertiary cause but
it wasn't the primary cause it was the
carpenter yeah
so that's essentially in a nutshell
all right all right
i mean this might be a long stretch or
like something unrelated but it reminds
me a lot of the whole discussion of okay
you know
even if atheists think that the universe
was created you know by nothing
or by no one
right um
you would still have the problem of um
from
no thing you know what i mean there's a
difference between someone creating like
for example the carpenter he uses
material objects a hammer and nails and
wood to create a chair but there's a
difference between that
and um you know the chair just kind of
appearing from nothing
you know what i mean allah he created
everything that exists from nothing he
didn't take you know this matter and
that energy and then
do this and that within create certain
objects he created everything that
exists in the physical world
yeah with but allah creates things
without any prior
um
higher material stuff
which could mean nothing
but there is another notion of nothing
that we don't believe in
because nothing means no prior cause of
conditions no prior cause no potential
but we can't say that because allah
existed forever for eternity and his
will and power were the causal
conditions to bring the universe into
existence
so it's not the case of something coming
from nothing
because the reason we say something
can't come from nothing is because if
you have a state of nothingness no thing
at all no prior cause of condition no
potential no anything then how can
anything arise from that
you need something an argument is you
need an uncreated creator allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and he uses his
willing power to bring the universe into
existence
but the other form of nothing which is
more theological nothing
allah creates from no prior uh material
stuff absolutely
there is a difference of the two the two
understandings of nothing there's the
philosophical nothing there's the kind
of if you like theological nothing
sometimes we make them the same they're
different and i wanted to mention that
just to make that clear yeah
i do i do want to stay and and and
listen to the splitting of the moon
because i'm super curious on that i'm
just going to turn my camera off for
like probably not even a minute i just
got to make some dua because we know
about the hadith about the for you know
the final hour before maghrib on a
friday inshallah so i'll just be right
back
so listen bro because it's gone long
maybe we should
uh it's up to you i could finish the
whole thing but maybe if you want to do
the whole philosophy of science the
whole
approach of the quran and science
we may have to do a part two yeah yeah i
i agree it's been almost two hours an
hour and 40 minutes yeah so it's like 1
45 a.m in the morning so
this would be the last thing let's wrap
it up all right and then
let's let's commit to
part two yeah we go through the whole
today i say i say we do the splitting of
the moon and then we can make a whole
new stream on the actual philosophy of
science and go into that yeah we can
even improve god's existence and all
that stuff
we were actually thinking of redoing
some of our old videos like why should
we believe in god why islam is the truth
and we invite you on if you want to join
us for that remaster that
definitely and plus i would i spent most
of the day doing uh finishing
uh
the 81 slides or so
some of them were already pre-existing
but i spent
most of the day on this and it would be
really nice to deliver what what we're
not going to deliver maybe in a part two
because i think it's important for the
audiences to have a correct approach on
the quran allah refers to natural
phenomena what is the main goal what are
the main goals that allah wants you to
affirm and conclude
how does allowing you to achieve this
and how is the quran timeless how is the
quran multi-layered and multi-leveled
that has this particular structure that
could talk to people from the 17th
century and the 21st century and even if
people have an inaccurate understanding
of reality they will still conclude the
goals that allah wants them to conclude
i call them epistemic goals yeah
and how is the quran timeless in this
way what makes it timeless
why is the quran when he talks about
natural phenomena always referring to
things like the oneness of allah and the
fact that he is the best creator that we
should be grateful to him we should be
in all of him we should glorify him we
shouldn't reject him it's a proof of
resurrection where does allah give us
certain epistemic goals when allah's
talking about natural phenomena what who
are the saiyan the people who ask
questions
right those with understanding
you know those who who
pondered those who reflect and ponder um
and so on and so forth
we have to be in a particular cognitive
and spiritual state if you like
in order to effectively
achieve those epistemic goals allah
wants us to achieve because if we if
we're not people of insight we're not
people who ask questions about natural
phenomena
we don't use our rational cognitive
faculties in a sound way we don't ponder
then we won't be able to gain what the
crime is trying to give us so there's so
many things i wanna that need to be
unpacked so the quran can speak for
itself because this whole science quran
debate has reduced the quran to some
kind of scientific textbook or you know
trying to prove its miraculousness which
is fine
in general but let's talk about what
what the quran is actually trying to
tell us there's a reason why allah
spends a lot of time
speaking about natural phenomena and you
can see an amazing pattern that allah is
giving us conclusions he's linking
the reflections or pointing to these
natural phenomena
within the macro universe and the micro
universe the human being
and he's linking it to a certain
epistemic goal a conclusion that allah
wants to have why is allah giving us
that conclusion and what is the link
between that conclusion and the thing
that allah is pointing towards and how
is it the fact that that that that that
when allah points us to the natural
phenomena and the conclusion and wants
us to conclude from the natural
phenomena how is it the fact that even
if you had an unscientific primitive
understanding of what that really meant
you're still going to conclude
the conclusions allah wants you to
conclude if you ask the right questions
you have the right cognitive faculties
functioning properly and so on and so
forth and how is it the case that the
the epistemic goals of the quran
with regards to the verses of natural
phenomena can be achieved if you have a
primitive understanding of reality in
advance understanding if you come from
the 7th century 15th century 21st
century how is that the case how is that
the fact that the quran is timeless in
this way this is exactly what i prepared
for um and we should do a part two
please inshallah
brilliant all right right let's deal
with the spring of the moon this one is
a quicker one to be honest yeah okay
and we'll try to wrap up the stream in
about 10 15 minutes inshallah inshallah
yeah so these were the main kind of
detractions and contingents from this
gentleman obviously online there are
other attractions and contentions
concerning so-called scientific errors
and you know if they come up maybe we
could address them in the future as well
so
allah says in the quran chapter 54 verse
1 the hour draws near the moon split in
two now the mufasariin the classical
exegetes i think the majority of them
they referred to the famous
splitting of the moon by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam which is a
miraculous event
and the contention is the quran says the
moon is split in two this is
unscientific this is the most ridiculous
ridiculous contention i have heard
because with all due respect the
commentators as i've just said referred
to this verse as referring to the
process miracle of splitting the moon
the very fact is a miracle means there
is no naturalistic explanation
that's the whole point
so it's not within the domain of science
to prove a miracle happened or not
or or the impact that it could have it's
not within the domain of science it's a
miracle it's it transcends naturalistic
explanation it's a violation of natural
law if that's your definition for a
miracle which i don't think is a great
definition because natural laws are just
inductive generalizations of patterns we
perceive in the universe and it could be
that this so-called exception is just
part of the pattern or it's an exception
to the rule god knows allah knows but
the point is there you know there are
more robust ways of defining a miracle
but we don't have to get into that
theological quagmire the point here is
this is a prophetic miracle how on earth
do you think science is unscientific
well science can't address this it's not
within the domain of science to address
miracles because it's a miracle and
america is something that has no
naturalistic explanation that's the
whole point
right
so one would argue okay well how comes
we don't we didn't see the impact the
scientific impact of this moon splitting
surely there was must have been
gravitational disturbance
no that's another assumption this was a
miraculous supernatural event that
transcends the natural world order and
it doesn't necessarily have to have any
natural effects or physical impact on
other than the phenomenon in question
the whole point of the miracle was to
create an impact on the moon and split
the moon it does and that's a miraculous
supernatural event it doesn't doesn't
now necessarily follow that the spitting
of the moon now should have
in an impact uh with regards to
gravitational disturbance
because you're assuming this is a
natural event with natural effects it's
a supernatural event it's a miraculous
event it doesn't necessarily have to
have
any natural effects or physical impact
as a result of it occurring yeah
so that's one point that so that really
transcends the whole this is
unscientific nonsense yeah
also interesting and this is something
that we could specifically say to the
gentleman well you know how can you have
a problem with this as a christian right
because don't christians believe in
miracles
right did you see the miracles happening
in the bible
no you just have to refer to testimony
right
we have to refer to the say-so of other
people
and al-quran the classical scholar
mentions this from a christian point of
view and if christians argue against the
splitting of the moon then surely
logically speaking they have to be
consistent and they have to deny the
splitting of the sea
in the story of moses musa alaihi islam
or the resurrection of jesus according
to the christians and other miracles in
the bible
because miracles by definition are not
within the domain of scientific
investigation just because a miracle
cannot be scientifically investigated
and when a miracle happened there isn't
you cannot see the natural effects of
that miracle
from a scientific perspective it doesn't
mean the miracle didn't happen
because miracles by definition not
within the domain or scientific
investigation so if you reject the
spring of the moon from this perspective
then you should reject everything be
consistent reject the whole bible with
regards to its uh you know stories of
other miracles
now obviously there is
you're working on your phd right yes is
this your first phd
yeah
okay
do you mind sharing what it's about
my my phd is on the crime and science
so
my phd at the moment is entitled
let me remember the title now
uh
a philosophical and hermeneutical
assessment
of
me and multiplicity of readings approach
so that jesus was the scientific
miracles
narrative and the multiplicity of
readings approach is what i've been
alluding to today the multi-layer
meanings and so on and so forth which
encompasses some stuff that you could
correlate to scientists or it doesn't
throw the baby out with the bath water
um so it's a philosophical and
hermeneutical um assessment of
and the multiplicity of readings
approach and at the end of the phd i
hope to show that the quran is timeless
the verses referring to natural
phenomena have epistemic goals that can
be achieved irrespective of your
understanding of reality
and
irrespective of the epoch or era that
you came from and that these verses have
valid layers of meaning within the
classical tradition and uh
and that these layers of meaning can
relate to different understanding not
only empirical scientific understanding
but it could be moral it could be
existential phenomenological and we see
this even when allah mentions the word i
did a case study it's in the slides and
we'll definitely have to do part two
i'll hold you to account on that yeah so
um in i gave a case study of the word
alaka to show the multi-layered meaning
and i could address ethical realities
scientific realities
existential realities about who we are
as humans
uh referring to you know the fact that
you know the
proof of resurrection
and so on and so forth there's so many
layers to this
it's an iman boost
and for me
it's a little bit closer to home because
unfortunately we reduce the quran to
a nonsense discussion sometimes in the
dao and it's a shame
it's a shame
and we have to revive
the quran as the quran let the quran
speak for itself
and when we do that and we give people
tools to understand it then it will be
mind-blowing multi-layered multi-leveled
um
and oh it's just phenomenal so
we're looking forward to that but yeah
let's let's carry on with what you were
saying
yeah so finally other contentions
regarding this thing are uh regarding
the historical evidence and but they're
not scientific in nature so we know we
don't have to unpack it here because
today was about the scientific stuff
however and we should note this just
because there are there is an absence of
historical eyewitness evidence external
to the companions
concerning the spitting of the moon it
does not logically follow that it did
not happen
yeah and
there's so many ways of addressing this
for example you could say that the quran
has a higher epistemic value meaning the
quran for other external reasons and we
can show
is from allah and allah has the
totality of knowledge and wisdom
the knowing and the wise
and also he has the full historical
picture we just they have the historical
pixel and when you look into
the philosophy of history you see that
when historians make conclusions it's
based on historical inferences they
don't have the full data they don't have
the full historical picture because
they're looking into the past they're
not living that moment themselves
and they're not living it holistically
not seeing everything that was happening
all in one god all the kind of causal
social historical connections no that's
impossible that they're not god they
can't do that
um so they it's not going to have a very
high epistemic value meaning a high
value of truth you can't say it's
absolutely true
even if you have you know lots of
historical evidence it's still an
inference yeah what we say is the quran
is
the criterion it's the differentiator
allah has the historical picture we've
got the historical pixel right
so if allah affirms it that's what we
really need and also we have the the
sahaba
right
and we're going to the philosophy of
testimony to show that that just the
sahaba statements are enough to believe
in what happened and this is not just me
making things up david hume the famous
scottish scottish skeptic he even spoke
about miracles and testimony he was like
look
oh his main argument was that we should
reject miracles
because the probability
of
the
eyewitness testimonies of being accurate
that america happened
is
is far
uh is is less
than
um
then then having a naturalistic
explanation it's more likely that there
was a naturalistic explanation than the
eyewitnesses
um being true
however and this is not really mentioned
by atheists unfortunately this is in
david hume's works and i mentioned this
in my book the divine reality
he says
however
hypothetically speaking and he mentions
the 1600s or something if there was
eight days of darkness and you know
masses of people came back to us
i think you know different times places
whatever they never met each other and
they all came back
saying exactly the same thing
and he says that i think the thinkers
the philosophers and so on and so forth
would have to would have to accept that
this eight days of darkness happened
this miracle happened
so he didn't reject miracles he just
wanted good eyewitness eyewitness
testimony to the point that is
equivalent almost to what we consider in
the islamic tradition as muttawater
a recurrent mass reporting
and the i and the eyewitness testimony
from the sahaba concerning
the spitting of the moon is that type of
recurrent reporting
so even david hume the scottish skeptic
he would if he knew about the spitting
of the moon and the eyewitness
testimonies from the sahaba
he would
accept that it actually happened
and this opens a massive discussion on
the philosophy of testimony the
epistemology of testimony which we'll
have to do another time to be honest
that's why they want to really mention
here but the point here is his main
contention is a forced contention this
has nothing to do with science it's a
miracle
uh it's not within the domain of science
even if you were to assume that there
must be some kind of gravitational
disturbance and there's no evidence for
that well that's false because you're
assuming that supernatural miraculous
event should have an impact in the
physical world other than uh the impact
it has on itself here so you know the
microscope is a splitting of the moon
and it's a miraculous supernatural event
why do you now assume and it actually
happened but why do you not assume
that that now has to have an impact on
on something outside of itself that's
that's a false assumption because this
is a this is a supernatural uh
miraculous event here
um that transcends the natural world
order so why would you think that there
must be necessarily
an impact
no
there is no even logically speaking if
it is if if we agree that it's a
miraculous supernatural event that
transcends a natural world order
then there it doesn't necessarily follow
logically that therefore it has to have
an impact in the physical world outside
of itself it doesn't it just doesn't
follow that's a false assumption
and also if you reject this then as a
christian you have to reject all the
other miracles in the bible too
so yeah so i think uh what we've done
brothers and sisters and friends all the
contentions that this gentleman has come
up with
we have shown that the classical
tradition
scholars
the arabic language the valid meanings
of these words
are not unscientific they don't go
against any established science or
established reality
and there are many layers of meaning and
the scientific errors claim
is a false claim
especially with the example that we just
used
so i really look forward to presenting
the wider kind of narrative on how to
deal with these issues
what the quran is what the verses say
concerning natural phenomena why they
mention these natural phenomena what
conclusions allah wants us to affirm
and how can we affirm those conclusions
and how does this all show that the
quran is timeless is multi-leveled and
multi-layered
and therefore we could argue that it
can't come from the seventh century arab
it must have come from the one who
transcends time
presents physical time allah subhanahu
wa
anyway so any points on this one
i'm looking forward to part two honestly
for your time and and guys let us know
what you thought of this if there's any
questions you guys do have inshallah
next stream we can do a little bit of
like a live q a at the end so we can
have you address something yeah
expensive one that's really good so i'll
do i'll fix these slides i put more
references and fix the spelling i'll
send them to you and then you could
share with your audiences inshallah
inshallah guys you should see them in
the description within one to two days
max
man bless you guys exactly for the
opportunity man
bless you
you know then you know i'm saying this
for a reason i think it's very important
for duart and
speakers and leaders like yourselves and
to act like yourselves to understand
this as well
that you know sometimes when allah gives
us popularity and fame and platform
we have to see this as a massive favor
from allah it's not something that we
deserve or it's not a right
you know allah says in chapter 49 verse
17
uh concerning those arabs who said to
the who said to the psalm that you know
them being muslim was a favor to the
process
but allah says no tell them
that iman had faith is a favor unto you
by allah
so if iman is a favor by allah then what
about calling other people to iman
it's a compounded favor
it's an undeserved gift so when we act
and interact online or offline as dua as
people who share islam
academically intellectually whatever the
case may be
we have to come across as if
we are not doing people favors it's
actually allah who's doing us a favor
he's given us the the gift of being used
to
to spread this light and that is the
attitude that we should have and if we
don't have that attitude
then i'm afraid no one's going to help
you the only thing that would help you
is a humiliation from allah
and you know if allah humiliates you it
will be it will be bad but you'll get
back up inshallah but you don't want to
learn mistakes the hard way you know
so it's very important getting involved
in this work is not a right
it's not something you deserve or own
it's a it's a gift from allah it's a
compounded gift
so
i just wanted to bring up bring that to
your understanding and this is not in
particular relate to you guys of course
but there's always some kind of online
fiasco happening every couple of months
and sometimes we just have to realize
that you know
you know this is when we we're misusing
this gift from allah spend all the time
may not bless you guys and looking
forward to part two
for coming on a very beautiful message
to the end may allah use us and not
replace us and keep us humble and remind
us that we are only servants of him
i mean may allah protect us from
arrogance and showing off and thinking
that we're higher than anyone else we
are not alhamdulillah
um except if allah wills that for us in
his eyes
so may allah
bless us all immensely
i think this has been a great stream i
don't want to carry on too long we're
just about to hit the two hour mark so
if i had any uh any final words
no that's all pleasure was all ours and
may allah elevate you and keep you as a
force in the da'wah and guiding those to
the truth
and also empowering other people that
are giving dawah
to your example with compassion
god bless you guys
i want to take a moment to go through
some of the super chats so if you guys
have to go on shot like you can but i
want to go through them and then end off
the streaming shots
take care of
alhamdulillah let me
try this out wow okay alhamdulillah it
works
i'm going to go through some of the
super chats here very quickly before we
end off so
uh
brother tsar says wouldn't it have been
seen by thousands of people across the
continents well actually
hamza i think he went over that he said
um just because it wasn't you know kind
of reported by x amount of people or by
certain people doesn't mean that it
didn't happen and it doesn't logically
fully conclude um you can make the
argument people have said something like
the indians reported it i don't know so
i'm not going to talk about that i just
want you to think about the potential of
it
maybe you're envisioning it in a very
specific way um like a more naturalistic
way like he said maybe like oh it's a
big it makes a big noise when it splits
and people were like oh what's that and
they look away um or this the um what's
it called
the there's no clouds or anything in the
sky so the moon is perfectly visible at
all places where it's night time in the
world at that moment that it took place
for a long enough time for people to
really see it um because it could have
just been the case that the people that
were meant to see the prosthesis
basically told them that was going to
happen and then it happened for a few
seconds no noise no other naturalistic
effects other than the moon splitting
itself and think about it if you lived
this time and you saw this it split and
went back together
after like a few seconds
would you want to go and report this uh
would you not be seen as a crazy person
if you or maybe a few other people saw
it if anything there's a few people who
saw in the few seconds that happened you
went to report it uh someone maybe who
is or isn't an astronomer or someone
who's looking at the sky to report these
things you would probably just be seen
as a weirdo anyways so what do you want
to report it what do you think that
you're still saying would you question
what you saw
the amount of questions that would be
raised to your your question um
basically it would all be arguments from
ignorance at the end of the day it's not
something that would necessarily follow
or not follow
so it doesn't really help
next
sonic constantly to keep up with the
good work and spreading the want to
religion of islam this channel has
helped me stay on my deen and is helping
a lot of people see the truth
allah bless you and keep us dead fast
donors you've come through many many
times may love bless you
live so
that being said inshallah i'm going to
end it off let me see if i can go to
this one wow looks a lot a lot nicer i'm
still getting used to this guys forgive
me
so may allah bless you all immensely
inshallah with that
for